madame monsieur bonsoir
voici les titres que nous avons
développées dans ce journal malgré le
confirme yougoslavie la célébration de
la pâque orthodoxe à belgrade au kosovo
au monténégro la ferveur des fidèles la
solidarité du peuple slave
au plan militaire des frappes plus
limité en raison de cette fête
religieuse et de la météo
nouveaux accrochages à la frontière
entre l'albanie et la yougoslavie alors
que l'alliance se relancent la carte
diplomatique madeleine albright en route
pour l'europe après le drame du tunnel
du mont blanc la mise en place d'une
nouvelle réglementation la sécurité en
question les premières mesures déjà
pratiqué obtenait au tunnel du fréjus
cinéma avec la sortie de gloria sharon
stone reprend vingt ans après le rôle de
janeiro lens c'est sidney lumet qui a
réalisé ce remake est signé à l'époque
par john cassavettes alors que l'aide
humanitaire s'organise au delà des
frontières de la yougoslavie
très peu d'informations concernant le
sort des albanais du kosovo rester à
l'intérieur de la province nous
parviennent les images sont très rares
en l'absence vous le savez de témoins
occidentaux je vous propose pourtant de
découvrir ce reportage filmé par un
journaliste turc qui a pu pénétrer à
l'intérieur du kosovo à 30 km de la
frontière avec la macédoine dans un
village tenu par les forces
indépendantistes de lui c'est qu'à un
village apparemment vidée de ses
habitants
le commentaire est assurée par notre
envoyé spécial jérôme bunny que nous
retrouverons indirecte dans un instant
un groupe armé de lui c'est qu'à la
guérilla indépendantiste du kosovo dans
le village de cot li na à 20 km de la
frontière macédonienne village investi
par les forces serbes le 24 mars date
des premières frappes de l'otan est
repris par la guérilla il y a huit jours
après de violents combats comme en
témoigne cette douilles de mitrailleuses
12 7
4 li na n'est que ruine comme sans doute
beaucoup d'autres villages du kosovo
depuis que les bombardements occidentaux
ont donné le signal d'une guerre à
outrance entre serbes et albanais du
kosovo
d'après leur chef les hommes de lui ces
cas sont aujourd'hui dans une situation
difficile
ils n'ont plus d'appuis logistiques dans
ces villages fantômes ou les maisons ont
été détruites et pillé ou le bonheur
n'est plus qu'une vieille photo l'équipe
de la télévision turque qui a tourné ce
reportage a recueilli des témoignages
sur des disparitions 22 personnes dont
une femme qui auraient été exécutés dans
ce sous bois avant d'être jeté dans
depuis vêtements ensanglantés
gilles est troué par une balle dans le
dos mais les villageois n'avaient
toujours pas déterrer de corps il ya
trois jours
rien ne peut attester que ce massacre a
bien eu lieu et le calot d'un soldat
serbe retrouvés sur place ne fait
qu'ajouter aux mystères et en direct de
macédoine jérôme ni comment doit-on
peut-on décrypter ce ce document ce
reportage avec les les réserves
j'imagine et les précautions d usage
oui bien sûr béatrice la seule façon
d'en être sûr ça serait d'y aller
peut-être que depuis trois jours les
habitants de ce village ont finalement
déterré et ses corps s'ils sont
effectivement là mais c'est un un gros
point d'interrogation
d'après le journaliste turquie revenus
donc il ya trois jours de ce reportage
les membres de l'ue ces cas sur place
ont une liste de tous les disparus donc
il y aurait sans doute effectivement les
disparus mais est-ce qu'ils ont été
massacrés dans ce sous bois ça ça reste
quand même un mystère qui est certain en
tout cas c'est qu'à quelques kilomètres
d'ici au kosovo les frappes de l'otan
ont déclenché beaucoup de violence les
plus extrémistes parmi les serbes
tiennent maintenant le haut du pavé on
parle des milices d'arcane les fameuses
et bleu blanc et donc du tout cette
violence provoque certaines demandes des
mouvements de population il ya sûrement
beaucoup de victimes peut être autant
que pendant tout le conflit au kosovo
depuis un peu plus d'un an
et ce qui est certain en tout cas
d'après les responsables du séchage
c'est qu'il y a beaucoup de déplacés à
l'intérieur du kosovo
tous ces réfugiés qui sont ici dans le
camp de brazda ils sont dans le
désespoir dans l'inquiétude de leur
avenir mais ce n'est qu'un pâle reflet
de ce qui se passe à quelques kilomètres
d'ici
avec d'après lui c'est qu'à 400 mille
déplacés qui sont entre deux feux qui
sont dans des poches de résistance de la
guérilla indépendantiste notamment dans
la vallée de la drée nitza et pour se
déplacer ils n'ont pas le confort le
minimum de confort qu'ont les réfugiés
ici et ils seront ils vivent dans la
terreur et vivent dans l'inquiétude du
lendemain est vive dans un souci d'
arriver au moins à survivre il y en a
qui peuvent être victimes des combats
mais aussi de la faim des maladies
c'est un vraiment un gros gros point
d'interrogation à un trou noir de
l'information qui à quelques kilomètres
d'ici
ce qui pose évidemment un gros problème
à tous les journalistes merci jérôme
baugnies depuis vendredi à la frontière
entre l'albanie et la yougoslavie des
affrontements entre forces serbes et
indépendantistes de lui ces cas se
poursuivre
des obus d'artillerie lourde se sera
battu aujourd'hui sur trois villages
d'albanais rendant très incertaine de
cette zone frontière
gérard guest beck finalement le chant
des oiseaux a pris le dessus
pourtant depuis plusieurs jours des
échanges de tirs ont lieu des deux côtés
de la frontière entre soldats serbes et
combattants de look chèque à cette zone
est d'ailleurs l'objet d'affrontements
sporadiques depuis des semaines donc
bien avant la guerre c'est par là aussi
que transitent l'armée de libération du
kosovo
les observateurs de l'osce et eux sont
en place le long de la frontière mais
bien impuissant pour empêcher tout
affrontement dans cette zone c'est la
première fois que ça dure autant il faut
vraiment qu'on surveille les choses de
près et suivre plus largement la tension
qui règne dans tout le nord-est de la
halle berry en réalité dans cette région
le tracé de la frontière n'est pas bien
définies l'albanie et la base arrière de
l'ofce cas et le passage des uns et des
autres se fait autour de trois pôles y
ait une véritable mafia profil de la
guerre ces images ont été tournées en
cachette en albanie il s'agit d'un camp
d'entraînement de l'ofce cas qui
bénéficie d'armements russes et chinois
acheté en albanie après la prise
d'assaut des armures il ya deux ans
aujourd'hui l'ofce carrossois une aide
des états unis bien que son dirigeant
s'en défendent
aucun état au monde n'a pas offert une
aide que nous les américains ne sont pas
en train de vous aider y compris sur le
plan militaire n'ont pas de conseiller
américain au kosovo non non nous n'avons
pas pas sûr en tout cas à l'otan on se
réjouit de la résistance de l'eau
tchèque
nous voyons que l'armée de libération du
kosovo lui ces cas est loin de là des
roches il y encore des combats des
points de résistance locaux et même par
endroits des contre attaques pour
récupérer du terrain au kosovo sur les
forces yougoslaves
dans ces conditions les affrontements à
la frontière ne peuvent que se poursuit
et ses tirs au mortier sur un village
albanais aurait tué deux civils selon
les autorités albanaises une trève
illimitée au plan militaire pour ce jour
de la pâque orthodoxe d'ailleurs on
apprend à l'instant que les sirènes
d'alerté ont retenti à nouveau à
belgrade
les raids de l'otan se sont poursuivis à
moindre allure depuis hier soir mais les
mauvaises conditions météo sont aussi
l'une des raisons de cette pause
apparente dans les phrases alliés
d'autant que christina était plusieurs
fois prise pour cible
washington qui renforce son dispositif
militaire avec l'envoi de 80 des
appareils supplémentaires vers la google
tv eric mené quelques bouts de ferraille
dans la campagne certes les missiles
alliés abattus par la dcn yougoslave
si l'on en croit le commentaire voilà
l'image choisie par la télévision de
serbie pour rendre compte des
bombardements de la nuit passe plus
question d'effrayer le téléspectateur
par une accumulation de ruines de
bâtiments fut main la stratégie du
régime est semble-t-il d'éviter toute
démobilisation dans la population
alors on glorifie ses actes de
résistance
ces chaînes humaines sur les ponts de la
capitale ou de novi sad
clie contre l'agression ils y passeront
toutes les nouveautés les derniers raids
de l'otan
il faut donc se contenter de ces
décollages de bombardier et de chats
sont de la base italienne d'aviano ou de
ceux de l'urss roosevelt le porte avions
américain qui croise au large de la
grèce les bombes de l'alliance ont ces
dernières heures principalement touché
le kosovo et sa capitale pristina où une
quarantaine d'explosions ont été
entendues la nuit dernière mais aussi où
rocher va tu es slatina nietzsche et etc
ralliez-vous de sources serbes trois
civils dont un bébé aurait été tué près
de podujevo au nord-est du kosovo les
etats unis ont annoncé l'envoi de 80
deux avions supplémentaires en europe
quant à la grande bretagne l envoi se
porte aéronefs l'invincible et ses
arrières appontage vertical dans la mer
adriatique
l'armada de l'otan contre est ainsi plus
de 600 avions mais les chiffres précis
sont gardés secrets l'otan n'a pas
fourni non plus beaucoup de détails sur
les objectifs de la nuit dernière se
contentant de démentir la perte d'un f
117 nouveauté les avions ont largué dans
la nuit en même temps que les bombes
deux millions et demi de tracts pour
tenter d'expliquer les raisons des raids
à belgrade épargné la nuit dernière en
raison de la pâque orthodoxe
des milliers de personnes ont défilé
dans les églises pour déposer des
cierges ou entendre les prières
et cantiques ont remplacé le temps du
week-end et concert rock organisé chaque
jour sur la place de la république
au kosovo en raison des alertes aux
aériennes dans les monastères soldats et
religieux ont dû eux attendre cet
après-midi pour à leur tour célébrer la
pâque à vienne et en italie devant la
base américaine de l'otan d'où décollent
de nombreux avions qui bombardent l'aïd
est ce l'avis des incidents ont éclaté
cet après midi lors d'une manifestation
qui regroupait plusieurs centaines de
pacifistes des grenades lacrymogènes
d'empêcher un petit goût d'approché
l'entrée de la base quelques
échauffourées
un jeune homme a été blessé les
autorités hongroises ont bloqué
aujourd'hui à la frontière un convoi de
camions russe apportant une aide
humanitaire à la yougoslavie selon les
responsables hongrois certains de ses 73
camions sont des véhicules militaires et
certains transporterait du carburant
dont la livraison à belgrade est
interdite par l'embargo de l'onu
je vous rappelle en effet que la hongrie
est entré tout récemment dans l'alliance
atlantique
la russie unie aujourd'hui dans une même
ferveur religieuse en ce jour de la
pâque orthodoxe mais aussi soudés par
une solidarité slave avec le peuple
yougoslave à moscou se sont déroulées
depuis hier soir les cérémonies de ce
qui est la plus importante fête
religieuse de l'année pour les
orthodoxes
le patriarche de toutes les russies
appel à briser le cercle vicieux de la
violence en yougoslavie nous
correspondant gilles rabin france brécey
dans ce pays où l'on n'attend plus grand
chose des hommes après dix ans de
bouleversements et des tragédies pâques
a toujours été une trêve trêve sacré
endeuillée cette année par des
bombardements qui frappe les serbes des
frères en orthodoxie
il prie dieu selon les mêmes rites avec
les mêmes livres saints et dans la même
très ancienne l'homme d'église
pas de trêve de fait sans pas qu on peut
acheter par tous des [ __ ] excusez moi
d'utiliser un chrome ou non pas de
pardon ni chanteur ni au ciel les
politiciens se battent les gens simples
souffrent à plessé contre l'agression
contre le peuple samedi les victimes là
bas c'est terrible surtout pendant le
grand canal
peut-être parce qu'en russie pour
beaucoup et depuis longtemps c'est
presque tous les jours car m ils
communient dans le même rejet de la
guerre et des politiques quels qu'ils
soient
vincent ducos la vie c'est tragique
j'ai de l'amitié ce la faute des
politiques je ne les aime pas fini les
nôtres ni les américains pour la
chrétienté orthodoxe la fête fondatrice
n'est pas la nativité la naissance du
christ mais la résurrection un symbole
d'espérance puissant dans la rue s'ils
brisent et d'aujourd'hui
maintenant nous avons une pac est
militaire et ont montré sans en français
je peux parler seulement de la serbie
parce que c'est un vrai choc pour tout
le monde porte dans ce choc pour ceux
qui cherchent l'unité des chrétiens
jamais les russes ne se sont sentis
aussi isolé d'autant qu'il peine à
croire aux vérités officielles qui
refuse toujours d'évoquer l'épuration
ethnique lancé au kosovo parmi la série
qui regagnaient temps dans nos journaux
comme certaines critiques et monique
d'autre part si le peuple le soutient
son peuple le soutient qu'il a besoin de
lui
en cette trêve de la pac plus sous la
ferveur des fidèles se cache la peur
très réelle d'une guerre européen
tous prix pour la paix l'espérance le
jour où christ est ressuscité au
monténégro maintenant les orthodoxes ont
célébré ici comme dans la plupart des
pays balkans la pâque orthodoxe et dans
la ville de sit in y est considérée
comme la capitale historique
le prince du monténégro qui vit
désormais en france est retourné dans
son pays pour l'occasion une obligation
morale celle d'apporter un soutien et un
message de paix maryse burgot gilles
jacquier les églises du monténégro
célébrer aujourd'hui la pâque orthodoxe
une parenthèse quelques heures de répit
alors que la yougoslavie est toujours en
guerre
ses fidèles monténégrins sont citoyens
ou de slaves mais il sur le plus souvent
opposés à la politique de slobodan
milosevic
mais en ce jour de pâques le
représentant le métropolite mithra lots
ne veut qu adressé un message de paix je
crois qu'on doit trouver un compromis
les peuples qui sont bombardés ne sont
pas responsables des coupables ce sont
les leaders politiques
c'est sûr que l'otan et l'europe doivent
se concentrer
l'église monténégrin de c'est signé
recevait aujourd'hui un invité bien
particulier
le prince héritier de l'umt et d'ego
nicolas petrovic négoce vite en france
mais son histoire le pousse aujourd'hui
à venir sur la terre de ses ancêtres
hier il visitait un camp de réfugiés
albanais aujourd'hui il dit sa révolte
d'insoutenables mais aussi je suis pas
très fier d'être français ou d'être
européen
avec
la façon dont l'europe et la france
aussi à traiter la question qui disons
le prince du monténégro voulait aussi
allumé un cierge dans le monastère de
c'est signé on repose son ancêtre mais
depuis la fin du royaume il ya 80 ans
l'église serbe occupent les lieux
le prince a donc été invités à quitter
le monastère
il voulait faire un geste de paix envers
la communauté serbe
il n'a pas été compris dans les bals
corps rien n'est jamais simple
le conflit en yougoslavie semble prendre
une double tournure d'un côté la
détermination des armes mais aussi
surtout pour la semaine qui s'annonce la
reprise du jeu diplomatique avec
différentes déclarations qui sont autant
d'indicés d'une volonté d'aboutir
parallèlement madeleine albright
secrétaire d'état américain s'est envolé
pour l'europe où elle doit rencontrer
son homologue russe la russie qui entre
à nouveau dans le jeu de la négociation
bernard lebrun au petit matin du 18ème
jour de la crise yougoslave
l'histoire retiendra que la patronne de
la diplomatie américaine a repris son
avion pour l'europe
sans dire un mot silence volontaire en
ce jour de pâques orthodoxe peut-être ce
qui est sûr c'est que madeleine albright
sera ce soir à bruxelles ici même où
siège de l'otan car demain les généraux
des 19 pays membres de l'alliance qui
dirige les opérations militaires
laisseront place aux politiques avec la
réunion du conseil des ministres des
affaires étrangères seule véritable
instance de décision de l'otan
bien sûr le durcissement de ton envers
belgrade sera à l'ordre du jour ce qui
ne veut pas dire que les politiques ne
recherche pas parallèlement une solution
diplomatique à la crise gori one off que
l'on voit ici se rendra mardi à oslo en
terrain neutre pour y rencontrer madame
albright et ce sera la toute première
rencontre officielle russo américaines
depuis le demi tour au dessus de
l'atlantique du premier ministre russe
primakov au tout début de cette crise et
paris de partager cette opinion sans les
russes
radi ses devoirs à rebâtir avec les
russes un cadre de travail et un socle
de travail pour la suite ça n'avait
jamais été complètement rompu en dépit
des déclarations
sévère qu'ils ont fait ils ont dû faire
mais nous sommes dans cette phase une
phase d'autant plus capital que selon le
secrétaire général de l'otan javier
solana je cite nous pourrions être
surpris au cours de la semaine par
l'évolution des positions de slobodan
milosevic qui montre des signes certains
de fléchissement sur la base
d'informations fournies par les services
de renseignement javier solana a aussi
fait état au micro de la bbc de
divergences croissantes au sein même de
l'état major de l'armée yougoslave
en dehors de cela les occidentaux sont
loin de partager les mêmes visions quant
au devenir du kosovo william cohen à
washington a pris position aujourd'hui
pour une partition du kosovo alors qu'au
même moment à bonn son homologue à la
défense rudolf scharping se disait
justement opposé à toute idée de
partition bref en politique comme en
matière d'opinion publique
le kosovo provoque les réactions les
plus passionnelle et les plus
diamétralement opposées comme le
montrent ces deux manifestations
d'aujourd'hui à londres qui se sont
croisés heureusement sans heurt l'une
contre l'otan et pro-serbe l'autre pour
les frappes et l'indépendance du kosovo
et en direct et de washington philippe
gassot il semblerait que le congrès
américain s'apprête à tenir à
l'initiative des républicains
un débat sur l'éventualité d'une
intervention terrestre au kosovo oui de
nombreux républicains de nombreux
américains considèrent que les frappes
aériennes n'ont pas apporté les
résultats escomptés
si ce n'est de me placer sur des routes
des centaines de milliers de réfugiés
alors des républicains et aussi quelques
démocrates voudraient poser sur la table
la question l'hypothèse de savoir si on
envoie ou non des troupes au sol et
c'est aussi une sorte de message qui est
adressé à slobodan milosevic disant vous
pouvez peut-être vous propose de vous
protéger en ce moment des raids aériens
mais sachez que le jour venu on pourra
envoyer des troupes au sol pour vous
chercher là où vous êtes ceux qui
veulent un débat au sénat ne veulent pas
que bill clinton et fasse trop cavalier
seul et bill clinton l'a bien compris il
rencontrera demain les dirigeants
politiques américains et il aura dans sa
poche
un chiffre qui est très éloquent qui a
évolué depuis deux semaines à savoir que
59% des américains acceptent aujourd'hui
de déployer des troupes au sol cela veut
dire que c'est américain admet qu
admettent
guerre puisse comporter des morts et
aussi des blessés merci philippe les
ministres des affaires étrangères des
dix neuf pays de le torrent seront pour
la première fois depuis le début du
conflit
réunis demain à bruxelles jean marc il
use à coup sûr on peut dire que l'unité
affichée jusqu'ici contre milosevic va
de nouveau jouer mais que doit attendre
attendre concrètement de de cette
réunion et bien béatrice on ne peut pas
en attendre des déclarations
tonitruantes mais cette première réunion
donc des 19 ministres des affaires
étrangères de l'otan est importante car
elle devrait marquer un durcissement
dans le ton le ton de la réaffirmation
par l'otan de ses objectifs en
yougoslavie et aussi des conditions
incontournables qu'elle pose au régime
de slobodan milosevic
avant même d'envisager toute éventualité
de suspension des bombardements
une réunion importante aussi parce qu'il
ne s'agit pas seulement de préparer la
stratégie de demain sur le terrain mais
aussi vis-à-vis des pays riverains qui
sont touchés ou qui se sentent menacés
par l'exode massif des kosovars albanais
troisième raison enfin les ministres des
affaires étrangères madeleine albright
d'hubert védrine robin cook fisher et
les autres vont également réfléchir à
des scénarii de sortie de crise qui tous
comportent un point commun comment
impliquer la russie qu'on viendra le
jour tôt ou tard d'un règlement
politique durable
mais en attendant l'otan renforce chaque
jour ses moyens militaires
merci jean marc il use depuis vendredi
soir le principal le poste frontière
entre la yougoslavie l'albanie a été
partiellement réouvert ce point de
passage permet de nouveaux réfugiés de
fuir le kosovo rien que la nuit dernière
plus de 4000 d'entre eux ont gagné
l'albanie pour ces familles qui ont tout
laissé la difficulté des rois apprendre
à vivre dans ces camps de transit
souvent le seul lien reste le téléphone
avec un proche
l'exemple peu ordinaire de ce kosovar
habitants l'allemagne et qui a retrouvé
l'ensemble de sa famille dans un de ces
camps nathalie moisan
et l'exode se poursuit comme la nuit
précédente une colonne de véhicules
s'est formée à maureen à la frontière
albanaise hier soir cac 1200 kosovars
massés sur des charrettes tirées par des
tracteurs et malgré le cessez le feu
décrété par les serbes
toujours les mêmes témoignages d'hommes
et de femmes brutalisé et chassés de
chez eux
nous avons vu des gens tués des maisons
brûlées
on ne peux pas le décrire
même les choses que vous ne pouvez pas
imaginer les ont faits on ne peut pas
l'expliquer ce sont des slaves barbares
autour de ces réfugiés de nouvelles
difficultés apparaissent
il ya d'abord le risque d épidémie par
mesure de prévention l'unicef a commencé
à vacciner les enfants de cook est ce
notre camp la moitié des réfugiés à
moins de 15 ans quant à l'alimentation
les rations distribuées par les
organisations humanitaires ne
conviennent pas toujours aux réfugiés
cet homme ne veut plus et l'enfant en
mange cela leur donne la diarrhée dit il
d'autres parlent de fièvre et de
vomissements et puis il ya ces douleurs
qui ne se voit pas mais que les réfugiés
commencent à raconter
little by little peu à peu lorsqu elles
ont pris un peu de repos des femmes
comment c'est à dire qu'elles ont été
violées
misc jusqu'ici dans ce camp il y a trois
femmes qui nous ont parlé des problèmes
comme
speak problèmes dans leur malheur
certains réfugiés ont parfois un peu de
chance ça huit mois rémi est venue
d'allemagne où il vit et travaille pour
retrouver sa famille depuis ce téléphone
sa mère l'avait appelé à l'aide
je veux ramener ma famille au causse où
il ya trop de monde il a trop de gens
mal à retourner au kosovo l'impossible
rêve pour les proches de saïd c'est
inimaginable si l'otan n'intervient pas
directement dans la province en france à
présent la communauté serbe célébrer
depuis hier soir la pâque orthodoxe une
cérémonie marquée cette année par
l'inquiétude croissante de ces familles
qui ont à belgrade wire en serbie des
proches des amis ou simplement des
compatriotes
reportage à paris olivier sainte-marie
et blaise grenu la pac
la cérémonie religieuse la plus
importante pour les orthodoxes n'est pas
vraiment une fête cette année les chants
et les prières vous l'êtes la nar sont
avant tout destinés à ses proches restés
en serbie dans la petite église
orthodoxe du xviiie arrondissement de
paris
pour la première fois les serbes arbore
une cible sur leur coeur
svetlana est venu se recueillir avec sa
petite fille et son frère mais là bas sa
mère c'est nouveau et ses amis doivent
descendre chaque nuit dans les caves de
belgrade
de peur d'être tués par les bombes
quelques heures avant cette cérémonie
svetlana nous a accueilli chez elle dans
la banlieue de paris
l'art la télévision est branché en
continu sur le satellite pour écouter
les nouvelles de belgrade
j'ai jamais j'ai jamais eu
plus besoin d'être la bac maintenant
jamais je m'en vais d travail même si le
bon bouton mon fils ce matin je leur dit
shadi à paris depuis tôt mais ces
enfants sont à belgrade
son fils est parti à la guerre est
depuis le 24 mars elle n'a aucune
nouvelle de lui mon mari est parti hier
par l'évêque à rabat une nuit là dès
aujourd'hui de nombreux serbes de la
région parisienne se sont retrouvés pour
célébrer la fin du jeûne
durant tout l'après midi ils ont chanté
et dansé sur des musiques slaves
mais à aucun moment il n'oublie ce qui
se passe dans leur pays à une heure et
demie de vol
il s'est vite on se fout pas mal notre
mère notre sang et notre âme
c'est notre caution à ce moment là un
homme intervient méfiez-vous deux ils
vont me déformer vos propos cet
avertissement d'être l'ana a toujours
envie de nous dire ce qu'elle ressent
j'ai le sentiment qu'à une chose les
albanais les albanais mort à cause d'eux
a causé faire je crois pas que c'est
vrai quelques minutes plus tard seul est
là ne nous dira qu elle garde encore
l'espoir que la paix revienne
pour cela elle continuera de prier
chaque jour la france a déjà fait
parvenir plus de 500 tonnes d aide
humanitaire en albanie en macédoine
c'est le ministre de la coopération
charles josselin qui en faisaient état
aujourd'hui annonçant au passage qu'un
millier de tonnes de nourriture avait
été donné par les français ce qui
représente 200 milles coni l'exemple de
cette solidarité à rennes où jacques
devaux et gabriel camilla ont suivi le
travail de la croix rouge une véritable
ruche en cet après midi dominical
ils sont une centaine de bénévoles à
s'affairer dans cet entrepôt mise à
disposition de la croix rouge
mais deux boîtes de conserve le second
il valait 1 kg les volumes collectés
sont impressionnants pour la seule
agglomération rennaise 150 tonnes de
vivres ont été recueillies les cartons
se font rares alors le conditionnement
se fait avec les moyens du bord la
branche française lorie en rupture de
stock au niveau des frottis folie pour
les familles de réfugiés
nous constituons donc des cartons ce
qu'on appelle des pales boxe chez nous
de marchandises complète donc on aura un
quartier entier de spyri tient cartons
entiers de sardines et c est là aussi
plus vite ça va plus vite pour nous
c'est beaucoup de la croix-rouge de
rennes a reçu 5000 appels de
particuliers se proposant de donner un
coup de main des bénévoles qui pour la
plupart n'avaient jamais participé à des
opérations caritatives
je pense que c'est pas grand chose mais
personne c'est même agréable voir ces
gens sont vraiment bons sons sont pas à
l'aise public fallait vraiment les idées
que j'ai vraiment besoin de quelqu'un et
je pense que les chinois
moi je me dis il vaut mieux avoir à
donner savoir avancer de voir tout
simplement je suis prêt possible c'est
grave ça peut arriver à n'importe qui et
je serai vraiment heureuse que quelqu'un
m'aide aussi dans ces conditions c'est
si peu de chose que de rendre un petit
service
à la croix rousse demain la poste va
commencer l'acheminement des palettes à
rennes il restera encore à récupérer les
vivres des autres villes du département
la mobilisation des français ne fait que
se renforcer jour après jour du jamais
vu rien que pour les appels
téléphoniques proposant d'accueillir de
réfugiés on atteint un chiffre record
patricia charnolé alice b tulard ont
rencontré une de ces familles bien
décidé à ouvrir leurs portes et leurs
coeurs ceux qui ont fui le kosovo les
lagarde et leurs cinq enfants
ils ont un salon de coiffure à boulogne
billancourt la solidarité est un
comportement naturel et l'habituelle
pour eux ils ont ainsi déjà accueilli
pendant plusieurs semaines les enfants
malades de tchernobyl cet après midi il
proposait de recevoir des petits kosovar
est impossible de voir des enfants qui
s'ouvre comme ça qu'ils ont dû piso plus
de pères numéro + deux parents c'est
impossible
donc nous avons mis à la disposition une
chose immédiatement pour des enfants
pour les accueillir et le temps bas et
viendront même à la limite s'ils n'ont
pas de parents et si vraiment ils sont
bien celle ou d'un on en aura une
adoption la générosité des lagarde
c'est aussi leur réponse à ces images si
douloureuse des familles du kosovo
les images qui ont meurtri et frapper ça
a été quand les gens exactement il y
avait un grillage et étaient tous il
paniqué il on pouvait plus et l'idée
d'avoir des réfugiés dit moi je trouve
que c'est génial
pourquoi ben parce que ça va réchauffer
leur coeur ils vont être si votre mieux
ils vont être voilà depuis vendredi plus
de dix mille familles ont proposé
d'accueillir des réfugiés
leur appel comme celui des lagarde
arrive ici à la cellule d'accueil des
réfugiés
les premiers appels que nous avions
étaient plutôt des gens qui appelaient
spontanément à la suite de l'invitation
à accueillir de fuji en france
et puis suivent en avant nous avons
juste les appels étaient probablement
coup plus avait été plus réfléchi au
sein des familles elles-mêmes et qu'elle
échange avait eu lieu une présentation
sans la famille avant de décidé
d'accueillir et de prendre ses décisions
d'accueillir des groupes de sujets du
kosovo des familles ou secours d'autres
familles c'est bien le sens de cet élan
de solidarité
voilà pour l'actualité de se confier en
yougoslavie je vous précise que demain
soir l'émission d'arlette chabot et
alain duhamel mots croisés sera
consacrée à la crise au kosovo autour du
droit ou du devoir d'ingérence
bernard kouchner charles pasqua alain
madelin max gallo et bernard henri lévy
la qualité à l'étranger avec bien sûr
les élections présidentielles en algérie
jeudi prochain sept candidats en lice
pour succéder à liamine zeroual qui a
écourté son mandat je vous propose de
voir comment un village de kabylie dans
cette région où sévissent toujours des
groupes armés comment donc ce village
considère cette élection reportage de
nos envoyés spéciaux
dorothée olliéric christian hutin
cette région montagneuse à une centaine
de kilomètres à l'est de la capitale est
classé zone dangereuse dans les forêts
sont repliés des centaines d'hommes des
groupes armés et c'est pour mieux
prévenir leur attaque que les arbres
sont souvent coupées officiellement pas
de couvre-feu mais personne ici n'ose
sortir la nuit on dort avec la peur on
marche dans la rue avec l'abs heures je
ne peux même plus rouler la nuit avec
mon camion pour repousser les attaques
terroristes les villageois ont constitué
depuis trois ans des groupes
d'autodéfense je ne raconte pas de
terreau chaque jour quand même il ya des
petites embuscade qu'on entend dans
l'alambic est passé à jour normale la
voiture criblée de balles il y a
quelques jours normal aussi le
terroriste qui l'ont abattu pendant
l'embuscade pour tout cela est devenu
une sorte de routine
et puis si ces civils armés ont le
sourire c'est qu'il y a un an ou deux la
situation des élections c'est un battant
pourtant beaucoup pour lui c'est
l'occasion d'un dialogue entre tous les
partis y compris les partis islamistes
l'important dit il c'est que la paix
revienne aït mansour le chef lieu de la
commune tous se disent lassés par trop
d'années de violences mais aussi par la
misère et le chômage
nous sommes en kabylie le pièce delta
remède le leader du front des forces
socialistes là les militants veulent
croire à des élections libres sans
fraude
les choses ont changé cette fois nous
avons eu la garantie du président de la
république et du chef d'état major le
général lamari la réalité plus complexe
et la méfiance profondément ancrées
quoi les gens à rage les affiches parce
que l on pas d'espoir et chic c'est tout
non seulement n'est plus chez moi à quoi
avec eux ne cachent pas d'inciter les
mêmes qui ont évoqué l'élection 95 6 ie6
eux-mêmes qui vont refaire les élections
99 10 points je connais c'est une
élection étrange disent encore les
algériens elle ne ressemble à aucune
autre
à quatre jours du vote beaucoup se
demandent toujours si les jeux sont
faits demain les premières conclusions
de l'enquêté sur le drame du tunnel du
mont blanc seront rendues publiques
cette enquête a été ordonnée par le
ministre des transports et de
l'intérieur
en même temps les familles des victimes
vont constituer une association de
défense afin de faire toute la lumière
sur cette catastrophe
caroline marie tire ici mené 17 jours
après le drame les spécialistes
poursuivre leur travail d'identification
le bilan provisoire fait état de 40
morts
la quasi totalité des véhicules
incendiés se trouve toujours dans le
tunnel
dix neuf jours après le drame les
questions restent posées l'incertitude
sur le nombre de véhicules impliqués a
pesé pendant toute la durée de la 110 55
heures à tmb la société des autoroutes
et tunnel du mont blanc n'a pas pu
fournir d'estimations une information
pourtant capitale pour l'organisation
des secours qui a donné l alerte les
versions française et italienne
diffèrent la société concessionnaire
transalpine affirme que c'est un usager
italien du tunnel à tembec côté français
déclarent que c'est l'un de ses employés
les société qui gère le tunnel ont-elles
fourni les efforts suffisants pour
assurer la sécurité des usagers comme le
préconisait plusieurs rapports
l'équipement des pompiers et est il
approprié
l'un d'eux est mort d'une crise
cardiaque dans le cynisme enfin la
question de la rentabilité à l'ouverture
du tunnel
véhicule devait respecter une distance
de 100 mètres entre eux mais cette
disposition est vite tombée en désuétude
face à l'augmentation du trafic
demain le rapport d'enquêté
intermédiaire sera remis à jean claude
gayssot ministre des transports les
premières conclusions seront rendues
publiques mardi
et en effet après la tragédie du tunnel
du mont blanc les normes de sécurité
pour le passage des camions ont été
renforcées ces nouvelles dispositions
dont une vitesse maximale ramené à 70
km/heure entrera en vigueur
officiellement demain au tunnel du
fréjus qui absorbe désormais la
quasi-totalité du passage britannique
le reportage caroline mari thierry
simonet le tunnel du mont-blanc fermer
ses 50% de circulation plus pour celui
du fréjus
à l'autre bout l'italie est cette
cohorte de poids lourds en transit
six mille par jour d'où la nécessité de
renforcer la sécurité exigences du
gouvernement
nous avons donc nos finances
petit clan ce qu'on appelle faire donc
par extension de feu de véhicule
d'intervention supplémentaire leur
mission escorter les convois de produits
dangereux et surveiller le tunnel les
patrouilles se faisait uniquement la
nuit parce que maintenant nous allons
donc tourner des véhicules donc qui
prend que les escortes et un autre
véhicule qui fracturent les patrouilles
et ça va être 24 heures sur 24
de nouveaux panneaux pour signaler une
réglementation plus stricte de la
vitesse et de la distance entre les
véhicules
autre mesure dès lundi le tunnel ne
pourra accueillir plus de 140 camions
par heure par rapport aux pointes de
trafic on en a au jour d'aujourd'hui
parce qu'il faut qu'on ait crête donc
par rapport au quota horaire qu'on va
nous demander
il est évident qu'il faudra qu'on les
stocks donc là ça va poser un problème
qu'il faudra qu'on gère risque
d'embouteillage et mécontentement des
chauffeurs routiers
c'est ici au ph saint michel qu'ils
seront priés de patienter la tente c'est
assez de pertes
une perte de travail pour nous et pour
le patron augmentation mais on passe
notre vie à attendre déjà dans les
entreprises s'il faut encore attendre
sur la route en plus payer le tunnel
cependant au monde la fédération
nationale des transporteurs routiers
demande que le quota de 140 poids lourds
par heure soit portée à 200
lundi la vallée de la maurienne doit
expérimenter le nouveau système de
régulation du trafic avec quelques
interrogations sur son efficacité
à paris la nuit dernière dans le 18e
arrondissement des incidents dont des
voitures brûlées des vitrines brisées
les jeunes qui ont endommagé ses
véhicules protester contre le décès d'un
jeune de 19 ans et serait mort après
l'intervention de policiers alors que le
jeune homme tentait de se donner la mort
encore ce nouvel attentat la nuit
dernière contre le bâtiment de la
perception des dégâts matériels pour cet
établissement qui a déjà été visée à de
très nombreuses reprises par des
attentats c'était le 19e cyclisme avec
le paris roubaix 273 km pour cette
épreuve qualifié d' enfer du nord c'est
d'italiens andrea tafi qui a remporté la
course tout au long du parcours une
foule de supporteurs dans cette famille
qui ne manque jamais le fameux passage
de la tranchée d'arenberg
nathanaël de rincquesen match et dojo
à l'ombre de la mine d'arenberg la
famille bigot a trouvé son petit coin de
paradis
quelques sandwichs déguster sur le
parking pour paris roubaix c'est une
fête de famille
c'est notre premier pique nique les gens
une de l'année la course parce que bon
il reste important mais leur marion des
espaces vivons on voit qu'ils sont en
train de souffrir quand même et c'est
ainsi depuis plus de dix ans lorsque la
radio sa folle c'est que les coureurs
approchent
alors les rigaud s'activent ils s'en
vont rejoindre leur place dans la
tranchée d'arenberg à 200 mètres de la
mine où ils ont pique [ __ ] une grosse
heures d'attentes
on s'amuse comme on peut mais attention
les choses sérieuses commencent cette
année paris roubaix s'est courue sous le
soleil les coureurs ont de la vence à ce
moment de la course 7 hommes sont en
tête mais cette échappée sera vite
rattrapé les coureurs vont vite passé
pour les rigaux une autre course pas
comment c'est arrivé
sur le chemin du retour les rigaud n'ont
pas vu andrea tafi prendre la tête de la
course le coureur de l'équipe ma paye
s'est échappé à 37 kilomètres de
l'arrivée lorsque les rigaud allument
leur télé ta fille a course gagnée sans
un mot confortablement installés dans
leur canapé
il assiste au triomphe de l'italien sur
le vélodrome de roubaix
football rouault a été éliminé dimanche
en quart de finale par sedan 2 à 0 voici
le récapitulatif des quatre clubs
qualifiés pour les demi finales
nantes le mans nîmes et sedan rugby le
pays de galles a battu l'angleterre 32 à
31 en match comptant pour la 5e et
dernière journée du tournoi des cinq
nations
les causes qui avait battu la france
hier remporté le tournoi après la
défaite de l'angleterre
voici le reste du classement
l'angleterre remporté la deuxième place
puis le pays de galles et l'irlande la
france se termine 5e de ce tournoi les
24 heures du mans moto kawasaki a
remporté aujourd'hui une huitième
victoire dans cette compétition le
français bertrand sibilo associé au
britannique a survolé quasiment de bout
en bout l'épreuve
le motard français couraient pour la 11e
fois et avait été victorieux l'an passé
et puis affluence record du public pour
cette compétition la course autour du
monde à la voile sans escale et en
solitaire les concurrents ont pris le
départ hier pour cette quatrième et
dernière étape
l'arrivée se fera charleston aux états
unis christophe portera
une dernière accolade avant de prendre
la mer entre giovanni soldini l'italien
et marc thiercelin le français les deux
marins ont quitté hier punta del este et
pour prendre le départ de la 4e étape de
la course autour du monde en solitaire
avec escales marc thiercelin a pu
changer de mains en uruguay
son bateau est à nouveau performant et
cela tombe bien les conditions de mer
s'annonce difficile dès le départ il
faut recevoir sa lutte voir n'offrent ça
va bien quoi pour installer le matériel
fait pas table plutôt dans le genre pour
ce 4 à 5
mais alors ce sera 12 donc il faut pas
casser pour cette dernière étape
les marins doivent relier punta del este
et en uruguay à charleston aux états
unis les voiliers s'éloigne des
difficiles mers du sud giovanni soldini
compte douze jours d'avant sur
thiercelin autrement dit un océan et
sauf incident il devrait remporter
l'épreuve marc thiercelin souhaite plus
modestement gagné la 4e étape
les neuf rescapés de ce tour du monde à
la voile sont attendus en caroline du
sud début mai
cinéma avec la sortie mercredi prochain
de gloria réalisé par sidney lumet tu
sais la belle sharon stone qui reprend
le rôle vingt ans après de gennaro lens
pour ce film réalisé à l'époque par john
cassavettes l'histoire d'une femme libre
qui découvrent dans des circonstances
tragiques l'art d'aimer un enfant et que
le corps nu langlois bernard ap
pourtant cette femme gloria est traqué
par une organisation de la mafia parce
qu'elle a pris sous sa protection un
enfant séquestrés par les tueurs de sa
famille est moins dangereux il doit être
exécuté lui aussi
gordien sort de prison prendre un enfant
charge ne fait pas partie de son
programme d'abord encombré par sa
présence dépassé par les événements elle
fait face à la situation
sur une base annuelle doit prendre des
décisions sur le champ c'est dur l'un
prend la tête pour arriver à devenir
accro sorte de mère
la lutte est inégale mais dans son
désarroi gloria obtient une certitude en
sauvant sept orphelins elles sont aussi
sa vie et donne un sens à son existence
sur le tournage la complicité entre
sharon et l'enfant fait le bonheur d'un
réalisateur réputé pour la précision de
sa direction d'acteurs c'est tellement
de temps à discuter avec lui pour
développer nos relations a confiance en
même temps elle savait être dur les yeux
moment dans le film qui n'étaient pas
dans le scénario
moi je m'en fous a été distrait elle lui
ai dit tu dois toi comme je te parle
écoute moi évident
elle a su obtenir si sa concentration
que ces screens ingame besoin moi je
m'en fous de crever aujourd'hui par
contre toi
tiens à d'état vient de bien trier les
toits je sais ce que tous les hommes ne
dise certaine modernité la forte
personnalité de l'actrice et
l'efficacité d'un vieux routier de
hollywood parviennent à nous éloigner de
la première version sans la faire
oublier génial d'avoir henry nous
interpelle sydney qui a dirigé à ma
premier chien c'est à pitonner voir
c'est vraiment excitant de travailler
avec quelqu'un de totalement les styles
malgré quelques effets outre et 7 gloria
nouvelle ne manque pas de charme
elle s'est montrée de la tendresse de
l'audace et de l'humour l'impressionnant
c'est la fin de ce journal je vous
rappelle les principaux titres malgré le
conflit en yougoslavie la célébration de
la pâque orthodoxe à belgrade au kosovo
au monténégro la ferveur des fidèles la
solidarité du peuple slave pour plan
militaire des frappes plus limité en
raison de cette fête religieuse et de la
météo nous vous accrochages à la
frontière entre l'albanie et la
yougoslavie alors que l'alliance folle
lancée car diplomatique madeleine
albright en route pour l'europe après le
drame du tunnel du mont blanc la mise en
place d'une nouvelle réglementation la
sécurité en question
les premières mesures déjà pratiqué au
tunnel du fréjus dans un instant la
météo présentée par nathalie rihouet
puis 20h52 la relève avec clint eastwood
vers orval le journal de la nuit
présentée par laurence ostolaza demain
dans les 4 vérités à 7h50 françoise
laborde recevra alain richard ministre
de la défense à 20h vous retrouverez
claude sérillon puis en deuxième partie
de soirée 22h50 l'émission d'arlette
chabot et d'alain duhamel vous croisez
consacrée à la crise au kosovo
je vous remercie de votre attention
excellente soirée sur france 2
votre